allons plus loin avec vous professeur
didier sicard merci d'être avec nous ce
soir je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
ancien président du comité consultatif
national d'éthique professeur émérite de
médecine à l'université paris descartes
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses
ces pays où le virus repart est ce que
c'est la vie normale d'un virus la
circulation normale d'un virus qui va
qui vient qui reprend ou est-ce que
c'est effectivement cette deuxième vague
qu'on redoute non je pense que pas une
deuxième vague et vous bien comprendre
que lorsque le virus nous a surpris en
janvier février
en fait ils circulaient depuis le mois
de novembre mais de façon complètement
silencieuse parce que le paradoxe de
cette infection
c'est qu'il y à 2 % de forme très grave
50% de forme moyennement grave un peu de
fièvre et 50% de forme totalement une
apparente
autrement dit quand des gens sont
malades
on s'aperçoit que le bassin de personnes
qui portent le virus est beaucoup plus
important donc dans ces histoires de
pékin le mans il ya la latte le traçage
honte est beaucoup plus
et puis c'est parti aussi d'un marché
d'animaux mais mes énormes vous imaginez
140 ha c'est à dire 14 mètres carrés
c'est à dire un kilomètre 4 2 détendu de
diamètre passé mais pour bien comprendre
parce qu'il n'ya pas que pékin je disais
qu'il y avait l'iran le bangladesh et
malgré vous nous dites en fait que le
virus était là est toujours là et ce
jusqu'à quelques formes graves qui
apparaissent non
les formes graves sont 2 à 3% mais elles
lorsqu'elles apparaissent le le foyer
qui est à la base qui est souterrain à
ses formes graves
il est considérable donc on peut
imaginer que lorsqu'on croit qu'il ya
plus de cas il ya toujours ces formules
apparente connu de circuler librement et
puis il suffit qu'ils se rassemblent
pour up ya un foyer épidémique qui
repart à faut bien comprendre que à
l'opposé les autres épidémies on repérer
immédiatement les gens malades là on
peut pas les repérer
sauf si on les teste donc faut tester
des gens donc il faut un test albasi fin
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il ya une
deuxième vague si vous voulez ça veut
dire simplement que maintenant que l'on
teste on s'aperçoit qu'il ya tout
pour une circulation des bus en revanche
ce qu'on comprend peut-être à la lueur
de tous ces cas dont on parle c'est que
la température
la chaleur n'a finalement aucun impact
sur la circulation du virus ainsi
probablement probablement aussi parce
que c'est pour ça que ans au brésil
c'est la saison 1 froide d'eau par
conséquent on s'aperçoit que on pourrait
imaginer que effectivement mais j'ai
quand même si l'on froides voilà masoni
fait pas tellement froid quand même les
pays africains le virus résiste moins en
pays sec et chaud que en pays froids ou
peut-être qu'il ya des cons facteurs qui
apparaissent microbien qui peuvent
favoriser au fond la gravité du virus
mais tout ça si vous voulez on ignore
énormément de choses la question c'est
est ce qu'il va y avoir une deuxième
vague ne le crois pas il va y avoir la
persistance ici et là deux foyers qui
vont être repérés beaucoup plus
facilement qu'ils ne l'étaient en
janvier février parce que au fond
immédiatement il va y avoir alors un
enfermement en janvier février on
s'intéressait aux personnes aux 2% mais
les 98% qui restait elle transmet tel
virus par conséquent l'épidémie se
répandait même si à la persistance du
virus on peut pas imaginer qu'avec une
société actuellement beaucoup mieux
préparé il puisse y avoir une deuxième
vague comme la première cela dit ce que
je comprends c'est que donc la menace et
la haye les attentes elle plane au
dessus nous européens nous faut
absolument mais elle plane mais le fait
que l'on puisse maintenant traquer le
virus fait que dès qu'on repère une
personne malade
immédiatement on va chercher son
environnement élus et repérer les
personnes qui sont en bonne forme mais
qui ont manifestement la capacité de
transmettre le virus donc au fond on a
les capacités maintenant de repérage que
nous n'avions pas mois de janvier donc
un parti que vont pourquoi l'épidémie a
été aussi dramatique parce que lcd elle
s'est répandue de façon complètement
silencieux si ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre que nous n'avions pas les
moyens doivent pas les moyens et on n'y
pensait pas beaucoup parce qu'on
connaissait pas on pensait pas que
quelqu'un qui était en pleine forme
physique la gymnastique était porteur du
virus et donc maintenant qu'on le sait
on s'aperçoit qu'il faut les traquer il
ya un point justement dans cette riposte
possible face au virus qui m'interpelle
c'est le fait que pékin ait décidé de
reconfirmer sa population tout cas lui
interdire de quitter la ville et de
refermer ses écoles éclairez nous parce
que nous en france qu'on a fini par
comprendre c'est que les écoles
n'étaient pas des foyers de
contamination important et pourtant voit
qu'à l'étranger on referme les écoles
alors on a trouvé à confirmer quand il
ya eu un foyer épidémique en province ou
sur l'avs et une quartiers de paris
l'école est fermée ou autant que les
autres il n'y a pas vraiment et on a
commencé par les fermer les écoles et
aujourd'hui on apprend finalement ce ce
pas si utile et aulas et pékin commence
par fermer les écoles aussi
oui parce qu'effectivement les enfants
ne sont pas malades mais peuvent être
être transmetteur il est légitime quand
il ya un foyer épidémique et dans un
village que roncq ont fermé l'école
parce que l'école va permettre même si
les enfants sont pas de malades de
transmettre le virus apparaît
logiquement va pas trop on va pas
arrêter le conflit on va arrêter le
confinement général parce que sous
prétexte que adore en dordogne a eu une
école qui a été touché est ce que
l'europe aurait tout intérêt à peut-être
refermer ses frontières à la lueur de ce
qui se passait là l'étranger en ce
moment là en tout cas c'est un conseil
qu'il faudrait donner aux aux autorités
européennes et les autorités européennes
l'élu ferme on va pas avoir actuellement
de chinois ou d'indiens ou deux
sud-américains qui débarquent on l'a vu
d'ailleurs récemment des colombiens ont
apporté les virus dans une région du sud
ils voient qu'on est dans une phase
d'allègement des prouesses qu'il a
connue durant sa maladie pendant
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
je pense que les frontières devraient
être fermés s'ils n'ont pas fermé mais
avec une quarantaine pour tous les
voyageurs qui viennent essentiellement
d'asie ou d'amérique du sud
on voit des mairies du nom voit
l'allemagne qui a annoncé par exemple
hier l'interdiction des grands
rassemblements jusqu'à au moins jusqu'au
moins
au mois de novembre on sait que
l'allemagne avait bien anticipé
l'arrivée du virus qu'elle avait profité
du quelques de la halle de l'avancement
elle disposait et que d'ailleurs ça a
donné des résultats
est ce que la france devrait aussi
saisir peut-être c'est avance qu'elle a
pour prendre de telles mesures comme
l'allemagne qui est en train de le faire
je la dépend quel rassemblement si vous
voulez si on prend un rassemblement dans
un stade de football où les gens
s'embrassent au son talent 40 cm les uns
les autres
mais si vous avez un rassemblement de
plusieurs centaines de personnes qui
sont écartés les unes des autres le
risque quand même extrêmement minime et
je vois mal comment on puisse interdire
des rassemblements dans l'état actuel ou
même en allemagne où le virus circule
quand même beaucoup moins donc je pense
qu'il faut quand même pas avoir une
vision perpétuellement sécuritaire
maximale il ya un moment où il faut
savoir quand même prendre raison mais
avoir les capacités
au fond ce qui change tout c'est que
notre capacité de réponse et d'isolement
des malades et par conséquent de ceux
qui l'ont rencontré beaucoup plus fort
donc je pense qu'il faut quand même
avoir une réponse
a posteriori que d'avoir une réponse a
priori sécuritaire alors il ya la
riposte au virus lorsqu'il est déjà là
mais il ya aussi et vous insistez
beaucoup là-dessus la recherche sur
l'origine du virus la chaîne de
contamination qui fait que le virus
animal fini par se transmettre à l'homme
cela n'attire pas assez notre attention
selon vous là encore pour ce qui est de
la chine c'est donc un marché de gros
qui est soupçonné d'être la source des
nouvelles contaminations par le la
envoie quelques images d'un très grand
marché qui approvisionne vous l'avais
dit en fruits de mer en fruits et en
légumes on n'entend pas parler pour le
moment dans marché d'animaux vivants
mais évidemment ce qui est interdit
vous n'allez pas voir la chine qui va
dire on a trouvé des points goal à des
chauves souris spécialement où c'est une
culture de base c'est une culture
fondamentale un peu comme pour nous le
poulet ou le steak à partir du moment où
tous les citoyens achètent
clandestinement des animaux c'est pas
cette vente d'animaux sauvages l'origine
ne s'est pas arrêtée par miracle
et quand les chinois nous disent sur une
planche de saumon de norvège
non on va ils nous prennent quand même
les planches servant à découper du
saumon norvège absolu a lancé le prince
et la mémoire pour une grande population
extrêmement naïve
ils peuvent pas avoué ils l'ont
interdite mais tout ça est très sous
terrain avec des sommes faramineuses qui
se passe donc comment on pouvait vous
sur un marché aussi gigantesques boss et
cinq fois rungis
quand vous voulez vous qu'on puisse
contrôler chaque étal et donc
clandestinement si c'est l'hypothèse je
n'en sais rien mais si c'est les mêmes
chauve souris
on peut imaginer que dans leur condition
d'être entravée de tous c'est d'avoir du
rythme que le virus soit ce reparte et
que s'il ya par hasard des pangolins
aussi les deux virus à ceux ci et donne
une chimère qui a été l'expression de
notre virus donc pour vous la chine man
who mais elle a commencé à dire qu'elle
allait l'interdire mais en même temps le
président dit la médecine traditionnelle
doit continuer c'est notre notre
richesse et parlement où les chauves
souris les pangolins sont une base et
médecine traditionnelle on voit pas
tellement comment une interdiction peut
être respectée localement je crois qu'il
ya là quelque chose qui est étonnamment
une hypocrisie particulier vous parlez
de la culture chinois c'est intéressant
on comprend bien que la chine est au
coeur de nombreuses accusations
internationales mais ce qu'effectivement
on n'est pas face au problème culturel
pro fin je voudrais juste vous citez
josé frèches qui est un spécialiste de
la chine qui a été interrogé par nos
soins sur public sénat et il nous
explique effectivement pourquoi certains
asiatiques sont si féru d'animaux
sauvages est vivant et je le cite il y a
une tradition en asie quai de manger des
animaux vivent ou qui viennent à peine
d'être sacrifiés pour eux c'est comme
nourrir le souffle vital
là bas on considère que chaque être
humain est possesseur du souffle vital
et que celui ci peut se transmettre
entre les espèces en particulier d'un
animal à l'homme comment on lutte contre
une culture ancestrale et on ne peut pas
lutter c'est exactement comme la drogue
vous l'avez jamais on n'arrivera jamais
à venir à bout la marijuana ou l'héroïne
alors on doit accepter ces virus qui qui
qui arrive sur nous et qui non mais on
doit sans cesse ne pas être naïf et
considérer que
les travaux internationaux doivent
travailler sur le port de ces virus par
les chauves-souris d' il ya tout un
travail fondamental même si les faits en
dehors de chine ne peut se faire au laos
qu'on lui a offert au vietnam le faire
en nouvelle calédonie en plus tard
demain tel endroit pour apporter du
matériau de réflexion parce que si on
compte sur les chinois je pense qu'on
aura jamais le problème l'embarras
chinois c'est que si ils interdisent
réellement façon absolument un carcéral
pénalisant le marché d'animaux sauvages
mais ça la révolution en chine parce que
les chinois il quand ils font pas le
rapport pour eux personne ne leur dit
que c'est ça dont qui continuent
d'acheter ces animaux sauvages dans des
étals absolument sordide puisqu'ils sont
ils sont clandestins
donc je suis frappé de voir que au fond
d'eux mêmes causes mêmes effets mais il
sait pas saumon de norvège sur une
planche s'il ya une distraction par la
chine de la responsabilité mais qui est
au fond légitime dans l' angoisse
culturelle de la chine ne se dire
comment va-t-on arriver à interdire
quelque chose qui est fondamental ça
fait comme si nos bons vous interdisez
des pratiques
absolument d'un jour à l'autre vous
mangez plus de steak ou de ou de poisson
le pourtant que ce ne sera pas interdit
ça veut dire qu'il faudra s'attendre et
peut-être même une multiplication des
virus probablement parce que s'ils
voulaient le à partir du moment où il
peut-être que je fais c'est que les
déforestations fait que les
chauves-souris ont changé leur propre
écologiques elles sont nourries des
d'arbres fruitiers et que eux les
capacités de proximité entre les grottes
par le train par la voiture par les
autoroutes entre les grands marchés et
chauve souris c'est quelque chose tout à
fait nouveau toutes les épidémies ont
besoin d'un responsable et ensuite d'un
cheminement la route de la soie sellout
de la chauve souris en même temps un
excellent moment où la route de la soie
c'est aussi le
l'exportation tous les ponts gaulle à
l'afrique vers la chine donc en fait
c'est tout un écosystème mafieux qui
fait que je vois mal comment on va
pouvoir avec des simples récriminations
arriver à bout et je comprends que la
chine soit très embarrassé mais il faut
travailler dessus pour en apporter la
preuve
moi je fais des hypothèses je ne suis
pas amoureux ne fut pas à pékin donc
mais ça me paraît la plus logique comme
un corresponsant parle beaucoup de la
chine mais certains nous avance aussi
les marchés africains sur lesquels deux
voiliers viande de brousse oui mais
c'est prouvé mais c'est pas la même
chose n'est pas les marchés hautement au
laos que quand j'étais là je suis encore
récemment dans les petits marchés au
monde est chaud sourit quelquefois un
point gaulle avait acheté un jour seront
marché donc mais aucune kravitz et un
pangolin on ne peut pas vous contaminer
comme salis 3 chauve-souris et si vous
n'en avez 500 qui sont entravés kiki
ceux qui urinent il y a une masse de
virus associé au point que l'un qui fait
que ça change absolument tout c'est pas
simplement une chauve souris c'est celle
hamas même de ce marché qui est
considérable mais on parle de milliards
de dollars on n'est pas simplement dans
un marché exotique comme si on allait le
dimanche siens à steinhoff souris pour
faire plaisir à ses enfants
c'est un marché fondamental c'est un
marché de base si vous voulez
malheureusement il est inaccessible aux
chercheurs occidentaux et je vois mal
comment on va pouvoir imposer d'où
l'importance de travailler nous
occidentaux sur les marchés africains
océaniens
asiatique pour essayer de trouver la
solution le manque de chercheurs sur ces
sujets ça a été un cri d'alarmé que vous
avez poussé il ya quelques semaines
notamment sur france culture qui a été
très remarqué très relayée à propos du
manque d'investissements dans la
recherche la direction de l'institut
pasteur au laos que vous avez créé a
reçu c'est ce que j'ai lu en tout cas
vous allez me le confirmer ou pas la
confirmation du renouvellement du poste
de virologues il était heureusement des
mois c'est votre coup de gueule c'est
votre cri d'alarmé n'ont semblent ils
n'ont pas brillé non c'est pas moi c'est
ça paraît évident que le bon sens disait
que ce poste qui avait été retiré en
novembre 2019 n'est pas le meilleur
moment est donc très rapidement le
message d'intérêt étrangères qui
finançait le post la rui donc que par
mots mais est ce que vous y voyez quand
une prise de conscience oui oui mais
encore insuffisante parce que je pense
c'est une chance fabuleuse d'avoir un
institut pasteur au laos quelques
centaines de kilomètres de la chine qui
est un lieu où on peut repérer
l'émergence très rapidement on peut être
sur le terrain tellement beaucoup de
pays qui nous envie d'avoir ces postes
il devrait avoir une puissance de feu
une puissance de moyens qui n'est pas
celle que l'on accorde actuellement où
c'est un peu misérable quelques
personnes ne sais pas c'est pas à
l'institut si vous voulez qui a la
capacité de faire des recherches
fondamentales
donc il faut une mobilisation
internationale c'est ce que vous nous
dit oui mais seulement parce que ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui beaucoup plus aimés
mobilisons internationale en demandant
non pas donnez nous la réponse donc dans
six semaines
un travail de fond pourquoi les chauves
souris sont et héberge autant de
centaines de corps aux navires us et
pourquoi ces coronavirus sont beaucoup
plus présents maintenant dans les
chauves-souris qu'il ne l'était ya 20 ou
30 ans qu'est ce qui a changé l'écologie
chaud sourit lassé des sciences humaines
l'écologie les vétérinaires
il faut travailler sur 7 au fond ce
chêne et pas simplement arrivé au
laboratoire pour dire quel est le génome
qui avec ses hauts fonds sa capacité de
nuisance
alors on parlait d origine parlant aussi
peut-être des traitements envisager ça
ne vous a pas échappé
énorme polémique sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine en france qui semble aux
clauses n'ont peut-être les études du
jeu claires maintenant je crois pas il
n'est pas impossible
certaines personnes la chloroquine
puisse avoir un effet manifestement
c'est pas le traitement n'y a pas de
débat là dessus
y'a pas le traitement y en a pas et
parce que au fond là très peu de
traitements sur les virus le sida a
mobilisé des ressources suivantes
fondamentale la dengue par exemple qui
tue beaucoup plus de gens dans le monde
en termes centaines de milliers il n'y a
pas de traitement
la variole n'y a pas de traitement donc
il ya beaucoup de maladies virales pour
lesquelles il n'y a pas de traitement et
donc moi je vois pas comment les
prochaines mois on va trouver un
traitement
ms parle de salles une percée
scientifique dans l'essai clinique de la
dexaméthasone oui mais oui mais ça c'est
pas une percée scientifique
ça c'est le traitement d'un choc
immunologique quand le malade à une
réponse un orage immunologique la
cortisone
c'est le meilleur traitement mais
beaucoup de médecins l'ont utilisé
depuis le mois de février mars pour
sauver les malades et je pense que ça a
une efficacité chez certains malades 1
sur 2 1 sur 3 ce qui est considérable
mais c'est pas le traitement du virus et
le traitement qui permet à fond à l'être
humain de ne pas être dévastée par cette
réponse excessive de la faune ce virus
il est tellement puissant sur une
personne qui va déclencher une réponse
immunitaire tellement dévastatrice
qu'elle va être au delà de l'art et de
la destruction du virus en en détruisant
les cellules elle-même parce que de
l'autodestruction l'autodestruction et
donc la cortisone elle elle calme
donc c'est normal et leur médecin que
j'ai rencontrés très souvent depuis le
mois de février mars
utiliser la cortisone chez certains
malades et observé des donc si je vous
suis bien assez peu d'espoir sur le
traitement un espoir sur le vaccin tout
de même il vaque swan est très compliqué
à faire ce vaccin parce que voyez au
fond cette réponse immunitaire excessive
ainsi on vaccine les gens qui font des
réponses immunitaires et donc le vaccin
contre la dengue dont elle avait essayé
il ya 1 heure et demie et on pensait
qu'on avait trouvé le vaccin contre la
dengue
on a essayé aux philippines il
est mort parce que cette maladie fait
que les anticorps contre le virus était
plus destructeur que le virus lui-même
donc il faut être patient on va pas
commencer à lancer des essais cent mille
personnes ce n'est pas comme la
poliomyélite ou cinq cent mille enfants
ont été vaccinés
donc moi je crois qu'il faut pas espérer
un vaccin avant fin 2021 et c'est pas le
vaccin qui va arrêter la maladie virale
va s'arrêter avant le vaccin
le problème c'est que ça va être un
problème parce que ce moment là
l'humanité va dire dans la plus besoin
puisque le maladie et arrêtent et c'est
justement parce qu'on a fait cette
erreur avec le strass 1 qui s'est
arrêtée tout seul qu'on a du bon ben
alors passons à autre chose
donc le problème c'est de continuer à
travailler mais sans penser que la
solution c'est le vaccin est l'appel est
lancé merci infiniment professeur didier
sicard nous avoir éclairé ce soir sur ce
virus si complexe